[Applause]
[Music]
as happens every year transparency
international has published its famous
ranking of the most
and least corrupt countries on the face
of the planet we are talking about what
is considered to be
the rolls-royce of corruption rankings
the results are
kind of sadly very similar to those of
last year naturally corrupt systems are
not transformed overnight and even less
so when there is an ongoing pandemic
that captures
all the attention of the public for this
reason and due to the fact that we
already have a video with last year's
results which i'm sure all of you have
already watched i'll pause here to let
those of you who haven't go and watch it
now what we're going to do this time
is not only take a look at rankings but
also take a close look at how corruption
can completely destroy a country
and how in the face of a natural
disaster or a pandemic its results can
be even more painful in this video we
will show with
concrete examples how some unscrupulous
people have made the coronavirus a
golden opportunity
to plunder the public coffers but let's
not get ahead of ourselves
let's start at the very beginning so
these are the countries that take the
prize
the most and least corrupt countries on
the planet any guesses
let's get cracking and find out
[Music]
corruption in the world 2020
as we told you last year as far as
fighting corruption goes there's still a
lot of work to be done and we have
little reason to brag
after all more than two-thirds of all
countries
fail dismally of course having said that
there are better and worse countries
according to transparency international
the five most corrupt countries on the
planet in 2020
were the following in fifth position is
venezuela which is already close very
close to giving the bolivarian
government the possibility of becoming
the world's number one so hang on in
there venezuela we're rooting for you
even if getting there is due to bribes
kickbacks and corruption of all kinds
coming above venezuela would be yemen
syria
somalia and finally south sudan
last year's world champion of corruption
according to transparency international
then at the other end of the scale the
most trustworthy countries in the world
would be
these six tied with 85 points each are
switzerland
sweden singapore and finland and
slightly above them tied for first place
are new zealand
and denmark wow i'm sure
you're actually not that surprised and
you see my friends if we're looking at
it by region
the ranking would look like this
[Music]
new zealand singapore and austria would
be the three least corrupt countries in
the asia-pacific region in contrast
cambodia afghanistan and north korea are
the most corrupt there in central asia
and the former soviet territories
virtually every country scores
very poorly but we still find better and
worse examples
georgia armenia and belarus are the
three least corrupt countries of this
group although only georgia scores more
than 50 points which would be something
like a pass mark but
for corruption and the awards for the
three worst ones in central asia go to
of course the stands uzbekistan
turkmenistan
and tajikistan here my friends
corruption seems to be almost something
ingrained characteristic it's it's
basically a tradition
you could say that if you go to the
stands and you don't pay a good bribe
you're
sort of missing out on the real
experience but anyway let's continue
in the middle east and north africa the
emirates and qatar stand out for the
better while syria yemen and libya which
are basically three failed states take
the worst rankings which comes as a
surprise
to no one in sub-saharan africa despite
what we might think there is some good
news
at least five countries pass the
seychelles botswana cape verde mauritius
which we've also covered in a separate
video and
rwanda the worst grades go to sudan
somalia
and south sudan bad luck there to the
sudans europe on the other hand
is by far the best performing region at
the top of the ranking are denmark
finland and sweden and the bottom
are hungary romania and bulgaria
[Music]
and finally the americas with canada
uruguay and the united states at the top
of the rankings
at the bottom well here my friends the
bad news is that with the exception of
uruguay
chile costa rica and the odd small
caribbean island all
of the other latin american countries
fail and fail miserably
[Music]
it's a region with a lot of politics a
lot of plans and a lot of promises
but now now is the moment of truth
beyond this around the world in 80
bribes tour the question
the big question that we can ask
ourselves is this is all this corruption
really that serious can envelopes bribes
hidden payments and kickbacks
really sync a country well dear friends
of visualpolitik
welcome to honduras
devastated by corruption
[Music]
okay so i know honduras is not the worst
country in the world in this respect
it's not even rated as the most corrupt
latin american country according to
transparency international nicaragua
haiti and venezuela
beat them at that game but honduras is a
good example of a country that has been
worsening in these rankings for
years and that in 2020 has suffered the
consequences of this enormous
institutional erosion like few others
have to give you an idea of what i'm
talking about in this country corruption
is turning into such a toxic web that is
turning the country
into a failed state an economically
sunken country in which violence and
political abuses
are spreading like wildfire a country
where it's estimated that corruption
alone could be one of the main economic
activities
check this out corruption in honduras
swallows 12.5 percent of gdp
12.5 of honduras's 2018 gdp was absorbed
by corruption in its various forms
according to a tally presented in
tegucigalpa by an anti-corruption
network organizations
la tribuna we are talking about almost
three
billion dollars in what has already
become one of the poorest countries in
latin america a country which in 2020
has meant nothing but tragedy
pain and an open door to corruption and
my friends when i say an open door to
corruption
i'm not joking
the year 2020 began in honduras with
president juan orlando hernandez's
decision
not to renew the mandate of the magi
wait for this acronym the mission to
support the fight against corruption and
impunity in honduras
of which the organization of american
states had deployed in the country this
body was created in 2016 to combat
corruption
in honduras well since that year machi
has launched 14 operations against 133
people including members of congress
and senior government officials take for
example the case of operation pandora
which detected how 38 high-ranking
politicians and civil servants diverted
millions of dollars u.s dollars from the
budget earmarked for the improvement of
agriculture to their personal pockets
and
also of course to the pockets of the
political parties they served in well
the fact is that after approving
different measures during the last four
years to make it impossible or at least
severely limit in practice the actions
of the machi finally
president orlando decided to kick the
mission out of the country which is
hardly surprising as it was a very
inconvenient organization for the
horrendously corrupt
but it turns out that that is actually
not the worst of it in 2020 we have also
seen some legal changes that
among other things have paved the way
for how shall i say this
a much more comfortable legal treatment
for the horrendously corrupt yeah
that's right that is not a mistake i
said more comfortable
you see during the month of july 2020 a
change in the penal code came into force
that reduces the penalties for drug
trafficking smuggling
fraud against public administration or
embezzlement of public funds
among a bunch of other crimes the idea
has even been floated that
for corruption cases prison sentences be
replaced with other less restrictive
punishments when the accused is
sentenced to less than five years
and the money is returned
[Music]
so basically you can take part in a
corrupt scheme and if you get
caught well by returning only what
you've been discovered to take
you can avoid jail and start all over
again
hooray but it doesn't end there
the criminal liability of judicial
persons is left aside
and we know how certain companies
operate in honduras we see
numerous companies that enter into
relations with the state and not having
criminal liability
leaves much to be desired rigoberto
reyes
honduran lawyer at the same time this
reform of the penal code has also
limited the media's ability to expose
corruption cases because of course it
has
you see my friends we are talking about
a reform that is already in force
many of the congressmen who approved it
by the way had pending cases
with the justice department against them
coincidence you be the judge find them
guilty and then they won't go to jail
but that president himself
has been accused by u.s federal
prosecutors of having received drug
money to promote his political career
and i mean what can i say it seems that
that is not really a coincidence either
all this is linked to a strategy a
systemic process coming from congress
and the executive
who have weakened already weak
institutions that go after crimes
especially corruption and drug
trafficking incite crime and
remember we are talking about honduras a
country where practically everything
seems to be infected with corruption
for example a study of public employees
showed that these same workers
considered that the two most important
characteristics for getting a government
job were to be affiliated with a
political party in power and
to know the right people check this out
in fact it is well known that among the
more than 220
000 bureaucrats in the honduran
government many have been hand-picked
by politicians which naturally no one
can deny that for winning the support of
civil servants
is not really a bad strategy you see my
friends corruption is becoming
so widespread that the ruling party
itself the national party of honduras
seems to have made this activity one of
its political banners by which i mean
that they practice corruption rather
than fight against it is even suspected
or rather basically taken for granted is
an open secret
that they have ties with drug
trafficking groups
[Music]
do you want some examples just a couple
well of course you do
and here we go fabio lobo the former
president's son
is serving a 24-year sentence then a new
york court has found that the
president's own brother is guilty of
several charges including conspiracy to
import
white powder into the united states and
just so we're clear
you're not talking about confession or
sugar for his part
the president of the national congress
of honduras mauricio olivia has also had
links with narco groups and
the mayor of brace yourself for a
classic grant pronunciation here taguchi
lauper and the presidential candidate
nasri asufra has accusations of
corruption against him
as for the president well the president
is actually playing in another division
entirely as i was telling you before
in an official document on the 8th of
january 2020 the u.s federal prosecutors
themselves pointed the finger directly
at the honduran president for links with
drug traffickers and even accused him of
having received money in exchange for
promising to protect those drug
traffickers and
provide them with are you ready for this
military support
to facilitate their activities mind you
we are talking about a guy who financed
the political campaign that brought him
to power with
a scheme that plundered 300 million
dollars from the honduran social
security institute that's
right from one of the poorest countries
in the latin america
the evidence gathered by the justice
department in this and other cases
leaves fresh questions about the
government's highest ranking officials
including the sitting president who's an
important u.s ally these officials
receive millions of dollars from
traffickers to finance campaigns and
cement their power
incite crime the fact is is that 2020
was a year that showed us as never
before
the implications that corruption can
have for a country and just in case you
think i'm still exaggerating
check this out
tragedies and violence
during 2020 honduras not only faced the
coronavirus but also
two devastating hurricanes two
hurricanes that left thousands of
hondurans homeless and hundreds of
thousands without access
to basic services an accumulation of
disasters that some have
nevertheless turned into a huge business
for a concrete example
check this out after the sars
coronavirus 2 pandemic broke out back in
march 2020 the government commissioned
marco bogaran who was then executive
director of the investment agency
inversion is strategic honduras to
purchase seven field hospitals with 450
additional beds to provide facilities
for the fight against
covet sounds reasonable doesn't it apart
from my horrific spanish accent well
hold on a moment because the operation
was a rocky one
[Music]
marco bogran commissioned a company that
had its business address listed as a
mailbox of a ups office in orlando
florida to purchase these seven
hospitals for almost 50 million dollars
amount that
trust me there's a lot of money for
honduras well it should surprise no one
that more than 47 million dollars were
paid without even signing a contract the
terms of which were between 12 and 16
million
above the usual market price and that is
not all despite supposedly being an
urgent operation the first two field
hospitals took more than
four months to arrive and when they did
there was a huge surprise they looked
secondhand they showed damage and came
with wait for it
no equipment for dealing with covet
[Music]
in other words they paid through the
teeth for hospitals equipped for
intensive care and what they received
were little more than second-hand tents
many months later and
by the way the businessmen who sold
these hospitals
of them axel lopez is a guy who
published a book in which
among other things he explains how to do
business in latin america including
advice
on you guessed it how to pay bripes
quite frankly i have nothing further to
add
your honor but take note because this
was not an isolated case
[Music]
several organizations have detected
other inflated contracts for the
acquisition of biosafety equipment such
as ventilators and masks equipment that
in some cases has not even been
delivered obviously we are talking about
a conduct that has cost not only money
but also
human lives and so my friends if you
think that is the bottom of the barrel
you are once again
i'm sorry to say very wrong widespread
corruption and the erosion of
institutions has also accelerated
another process
the conversion of honduras into a narcos
state
well earlier we talked about the
frequent relations between the political
class and drug trafficking groups i can
now
also tell you how violence is taking
over the country and even how coca crops
are beginning
to spread throughout the honduran
geography and so this
this is how honduras is walking towards
becoming a failed state
this is the story of how corruption is
devouring this small central american
country but now the question is over to
you
how much do you think corruption could
be overcome in this type of country
leave your answer
in the comments below as always we
really hope you enjoyed this video
please hit a like if you did and don't
forget to subscribe for brand new videos
take it easy guys and as always i'll see
you next time
and if you want to learn more about
politics and hear even more of my lovely
voice
you can join us at reconsider media we
have a podcast at reconsider
media.com podcast see you there